>> THE ENGINE THE
BEST IS LEAD HIM.
THIS IS A LONGIT IN , NUMBER 63
VICTOR THINKS, OH, HE'S GOING
TO COME WITH ME IN THE MIDDLE A
NUMBER TWO CENTER.
REPLACING DAVID KREJCI.
BOTH ENDS ON THE
POWER
POINTS.
KUCHEROV TAKES IT LEFTY ON THE
RIGHT-WING SIDE.
THIS IS THE INITIAL ATTACK AND
PERIOD.
GREAT THEIR THE
SPACE THERE.
WE'RE  ONE
OF THEIR OFFENSES.
THREE SHOTS ON BENJAMIN
NETANYAHU
BOARDS OFF OF A PLAYER RRY, L.
USE THE BOARDS AROUND THE BACK
FROM BEHIND, , STAMKOS.
HEAVY HERE.
NOW,  ALEX KILLWERE ON.
SHOVELED THAT INTO THE AND WITH
BY BERGERON AND MARCHAND.
IN THE BEST
WINGERS IN THE LEAGUE.
WATCH IT HERE.
BOGOSIAN IS A RIGHTY PLAYING
THE LEFT SIDE AND IS FOR ERIC A
THE SHOT T CAN BRIG IT.
REILLY WITH OWN ZONE.
>> Dave: STAYS WITH SCREEN.
PALAT TAMES OUT MCAVOY
AROUND IN THE OFFENSIVE ZONE
AFTER THAT POINT CHANCE.
THEY KEPT COMING AND COMINGNGFO
BELLEMARARFOR THE
BROWNS.
HERE WE GO.
BUCKLE UP.
FOURTH CERNAK.
AND CUTS BACK.
ON ARE GOING
TO BE SOLID CHECKERS.
YOU HAVE